mouths dream asks what are your thoughts
on using Kickstarter to start a business
mount dream
what climb that mountain mouth dream at
Kickstarter first of all I think it's a
great way to start a business tons of
people have starting businesses on the
back of Kickstarter didn't oculus rift
start in the back of Kickstarter and
sold for to Billy on Facebook so what do
I think I think it works here's what
else I think I think there's a lot of
people that put [ __ ] businesses on
Kickstarter this is a classic question
of do you think this platform can work
to do X the answer is always yes
especially when it's already happened
the problem is the second do I think
people can make a million dollars
selling on eBay yes the talented ones do
I think you can make a lot of money by
making YouTube videos yes the talented
ones do I think that you could become a
buying celebrity on vine and make lots
of money millions yes the talented ones
and so over and over my classic do I
think a basketball has an ROI I do
LeBron makes a [ __ ] LeBron will be a
billionaire because of a basketball
that's the ROI of it I will not
so can Kickstarter be a great platform
to kick off the business it can but
people that have bought into this notion
of oh it's easy just go and Kickstarter
people are gonna give you money and you
start a business they're lost hello st
lost and that is the problem in our
society right now
all of this works you have the talent to
execute